make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
all right people you guys knew it was
coming you guys knew was only ever a
matter of time before we did something
like this too powerful for Marvel movies
Hyperion alright here's the thing we're
doing Secret Wars Hyperion the good
version of Hyperion right like we're not
doing any of the ones that came before
we're not doing maybe we'll go I could
do it at some point we're like maybe
we'll do like squadron supreme Hyperion
or like King Hyperion or some like that
but in this one we are doing Secret Wars
type here let me just let me tell you
guys some dude the progression of Secret
Wars Hyperion dude him and Thor had like
the best bromance ever all do was it was
the coolest thing so here's the here's
the whole thing with Hyperion right like
earth one three zero three four alright
this was an alternate reality where
Hyperion was an eternal what does that
mean and basically he was created by the
Celestials the whole idea behind we know
we should probably count we've explained
that so many times okay one day the
Celestials showed up on earth they
modify the genes of early man and some
of those beings they modified went
forward as like angelic like beings with
incredible powers that's basically where
the Eternals come from anyway then an
alternate reality is crazy Jonathan
Hickman wrote this and he's like you
know what like let's like Hyperion's
always been an allegory for Superman in
for a penny in for a pound so he's like
Superman this is it's crazy
so Hyperion was an eternal on a distant
planet in another universe who basically
basically like his planet exploded like
his planet was gonna was gonna be
destroyed and so like his family like
his parents sent him from that planet to
earth where he was raised by this guy
and in turn taught like morality and
things like that he's basically is
basically the story of Superman is it's
like it's like the story of Superman but
for a guy called Hyperion instead of
Superman anyway the craziest display of
power from Hyperion alright the craziest
display of power during the incursions
when universes were crashing into each
other the focal points was earth right
like if the Earth's touch then the
universes collapse lay the universes
will basically be wiped out now we know
that like in order like if you if you
try to push back in earth you're
effectively trying to push back a whole
other universe right like we knew that
from the first arc of New Avengers when
Captain America tried to use the
Infinity Gauntlet and like destroyed all
the Infinity stones right so that's
important to know because during the
incursions when one universe was gonna
crash into the universe of Hyperion the
alternate reality he was in earth 1 3 0
3 4 there's basically a point where like
all the superheroes including Hyperion
in that alternate reality are trying to
stop the incursions like trying to stop
everything and basically it comes down
period and he holds apart two universes
with his bare hands he keeps like he
pushes two universes apart and almost it
almost works for like five minutes total
he's like pushing two universes apart
five minutes is not a long time but like
it's two universes though let's see you
push two universes apart like hold two
universes apart for five minutes
but like little he's like holding them
apart for five minutes and then like
like literally they caught they crash
into each other his and his whole
universe is destroyed and he still lives
he's just floating out there in space
now eventually aim like pierces through
into that alternate reality they grab
him they bring him into the main male
universe and basically he's held captive
by aim for a little while until he's
rescued by the Avengers and it was the
craziest thing ever right because he's
basically like Superman he's got like
this moral compass like hey I'm a good
guy we do good things and so forth then
he gets corrupted by Thor and it's like
the coolest thing ever is the best thing
Thor's like have some meat and
Hyperion's like I don't do that my dad
taught me that alcohol is bad
Thor is over here like like Thor's do it
like Goines like he's he's all like
battle you know and like battle stuff
eventually like it starts rubbing off on
Hyperion and so like like Hyperion and
Thor become like do they become grossed
like like they're they're like relishing
in battle and Hyperion grows like a
ponytail it's like the craziest thing so
like like these two guys are like the
battle-hardened warriors of like the
Avengers right so then like Robert
Acosta who's basically sunspot who's
like a really really rich guy the whole
incursions and everything are happening
so he's like we need a multiversal
Avengers team to go into the multiverse
and figure out what's causing the
incursion so you get like the
multiversal Avengers here's one of the
coolest things ever it's like it's like
like what was it it is star brand and
Thor and Hyperion and Knight mask you
can teleport anywhere across the
universe and then like a couple other
care I think one or two other characters
or something like that anyway they end
up jumping from like one universe to the
next like literally hopping around the
multiverse until they come across one
universe where there's there's nothing
there's no life or anything like there's
no planets no stars just a giant empty
void with like this this rift like this
this tear in the fabric of that universe
and it leads to the beyond verse and
they're just like okay we found like we
found almost going on we found the
beyonders and like what like a couple of
them come out and a couple of them are
just like okay so like you guys need to
leave because like we're doing an
experiment and if you guys stay here
then you're gonna cause problems so like
get out of here and in Thor like like
all the multiversal vendors just like
whatever man like like we are we're
doing our thing like like you guys
we're gonna destroy you guys you guys
have to stop all this stuff you know
whatever so like one of them like they
like both beyonders literally go to
attack the the multiversal Avengers and
like one of them Pierce's Pierce's star
brand who literally explodes with like
an infinite amount of power and kills
that kills one of the beyonders and it's
just like that's impossible and then the
other guy ex nihilo that's what it was
the the life crater the the life maker
actually helo and them are called
gardeners basically like they go into
worlds and then like seed world so they
can basically have like trees and life
and things like that they literally
create life on planets and so like they
end up modifying one of the one of the
beyonders and like turn them into like a
giant tree or something on those lines
anyway it's a craziest thing because
like in the process like Thor's arm gets
ripped off again like Hyperion gets
blinded you know and it's just like it's
like okay it's like they're the last two
left dude it's the most ridiculous the
most beast thing ever Thorin Hyperion
are sitting there chilling and
Hyperion's like we're gonna die here and
Thor's like yeah but if we're gonna die
let us die a Warrior's death it's the
most beasts thing because because I
periods like he's like brother he's like
he's like he's like Thor I'll see you at
Valhalla and and Thor's like brother
today I'll race you there and they go
like racing again like running up on all
these different like be honors cuz the
honors come like pouring out of this
rift right there's like by countless
beyonders come pouring out of the rift
and like Thor hype here and just go
flying into him and it's just like this
insane battle and like this huge empty
void and there's like these captions
right and it's just like like in the
bleak spans a bleak expansive of
nothingness like two gods fell against
many it's like there was a crack of
thunder and then silence and it's just
like Jam do they they died who they went
out like heroes man it was new hmm
perimeters look Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and new you know matter of fact
we're gonna continue remastering it
whatever people gonna be like you
uploaded this once before
yep and then we're gonna go back to
remaster it so like it's one of the dude
it's one of the most beast things
dude it's one of it's one of the coolest
things ever but here's the thing if
Hyperion was thrown into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it wouldn't even be
that he's too powerful for the
superheroes like because he would be he
would be a superhero right like he'd be
too powerful for the villains do cuz let
me tell you something man I would bet
all the money in my pockets - all the
money in your pockets you put I peer in
against hella I'll do even mop the floor
with hell it wouldn't be funny like it I
mean there's no one a guy who held two
universes apart you're telling me that
hell is gonna stand a chance
well she's technically immortal because
she's like an aspect of death but it
doesn't mean you can't get beat up so
like like Hyperion would probably wreck
her pretty bad
thanos I'll do things by himself like
without the Infinity Gauntlet no chance
by Hyperion would he would you tear him
apart like tear him limb from limb
daddles is powerful and strong but he
ain't that powerful and strong I mean
he's cool but like I mean but you know
like like Hyperion would definitely be
able to like he would he'd mop the floor
with Nana's other people like Dormammu
yeah he would crush Hyperion like like
people like nightmare depending on the
circumstance for the day as you don't
know nightmares of Doctor Strange
villain Bryton like he exists in a realm
called The Nightmare Realm which makes
sense because his name is nightmare and
he's basically like powered by the
nightmares of people the guy's like a
dick I mean you could probably kind of
figure it out like he's kind of a dick
and it's true but but still like like he
would be he'd probably be able to crush
ipiria I mean there's a lot of people
out there who could like crush Hyperion
but if you take him and you throw him on
the Avengers team Oh uh-huh
I mean Hyperion can go toe-to-toe with
The Incredible Hulk and that's not an
easy feat right like people leave a look
at the MCU and like man Carol Danvers
are strong not really like you put
there's one point in the comics like
you're in Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers and like like Carol Danvers get
the Incredible Hulk she just starts like
pounding away on it like hounding him
into the ground just like like giving it
a given giving like everything she's got
and they're like when they when the
smoke clears like the incredible looks
just laying there like with his hands
behind his head he's just smiling he's
like are you done and they're just like
bad like sends her flying I mean it is
it's that's the thing like Hyperion in
the MCU it has to be comic book Hyperion
squadron supreme is cool and it'd be an
obvious ripoff of Jesus Justice Li
because that's what it was and in Marvel
Comics and that'd be kind of ironic as
people would be like man I want to see
how this plays out I mean if you really
want like a ripoff of DC's Justice
League look at the Great Society yeah
the Great Society was basically like
like literally the most tried and true
ripoff of the Justice League ever like
it was it was it's not even funny they
had flash basically Batman they had
essentially Superman basically Wonder
Woman like I mean it was it was it was
it's pretty insane like even squatter
supreme to a degree is like that is more
so now than it was before but still it's
cool because it's Hyperion represents
like Hyperion has a character that we
haven't seen before right because when
you look at someone like Thor Thor can't
fly without his hammer right like he has
to spin his little hammer and then sit
in a direction and like he follows the
holds a hammer in the hammer flops but
like Hyperion be as close as the Marvel
Cinematic Universe would get to Superman
and and he would he would do some damage
I mean almost anybody that would face
off it lately he would face off against
he would do some damage here's the thing
if during the events of infinity war
Hyperion was there I cannot stress this
enough if during the events of infinity
war Hyperion was there and like like he
was the one that fought Thanos in the
beginning of the movie has said of The
Incredible Hulk
oh he would he would have decimated him
oh it would have been an absolute
murdering man it would have been nuts
like it would have it would have been
mockers anyway yes
Hyperion is way too powerful for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe having said
that he needs to be in there because
he's one of the coolest characters out
there they're gonna nerf him definitely
gonna reduce his power but still like
Hyperion needs to be in the MCU well
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explain make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the robb core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you